yeah hello and welcome to this video
were playing so Schmitt with black in
this record game only chair so play the
French defense that just came to my mind
while reading about the French election
well actually not about the election but
about yeah I don't know but what's the
what's the name there okay about this
transition from long to Macomb which is
happening today a day when I record this
so we got a French classical by
transposition with an early night f3 so
let's see what white does I think they
usually take on c5 here I think there is
a recce line we should g5 as well
mucho
yeah but Queen b6 cannot be bad against
this so in white more or less and has to
take maybe you can play random 92 or
something with the usual idea with the
Knight f3 setup here is to take on c5
and then support the center with pieces
Bishop to b5
hmm so 96 looks the most natural Bishop
e5 to quite no can also go a six and
make him take basically
yeah I mean that cannot be bad it loses
a bit of time but the term it also
develops me a little bit here
okay I'm 96
looks extremely natural an interesting
question however arises here what now
I wonder if be sixes and moves just to
cover it with a pawn I mean white setup
is not very aggressive I think this is
an interesting choice just see what he
does here maybe he just plays 92 and c3m
okay maybe that wasn't the best idea
ever I could have taken him after which
he would have been forced to take with
the bishop Knight takes Knight takes e5
and I have the six is probably not so
good 92 is a useful move anyway and you
don't quite know if b6 was helpful
probably not
yeah white takes quite a while here move
that you cannot play as take on c5 and
then that this is wrong
after B take c5 is in the position of
course he can centralize the arrow key
one most like that 92 whatever looks
like the most purposeful idea get the
night over there prepare c3 to support
the center a little bit more it seems
seems like the most likely choice
you don't quite quite see them you need
for such a long thing here I wonder what
is try to figure out
yeah you know I would probably play 92m
I will see something completely
different there okay be again Mookie one
or maybe Queen d2 one so those moves are
somewhat yeah somewhat fitting into this
position would still fit surprised that
you take so long is connected
hmm bit mysterious maybe he was
absolutely certain depth I would take on
d4 and then he gets a default square
which is not happening now I have to be
six
it's a bit bit strange with it taking so
long
it cannot collective a winning at some
point I think only when the side turn
when the site detects a disconnection
then you can do it I have a little bit
how to believe that is really thinking
about this okay okay one so again I want
to keep the scansion don't want to take
a three that is the move I don't like
all that much light a 5 c4 becomes more
interesting how do I want to do it yeah
why not
a3 weakens the light squares indirectly
c4 is a light square and denied wants to
go down roll
I can just take the pawn but it's not
stress again so takes that that doesn't
work okay if I go 9c for here
immediately
Knight to Knight takes d5 I can just
take okay that doesn't work so let's get
to them
no before was a strange kind of an
overreaction the position wasn't wasn't
bad for white and these nothing that I
felt was anything dramatic
and support this whoopsie eight would be
a good follow up to make more pressure
on c3 he currently has lots of stuff on
that diagonal yes that's an interesting
one so I don't win material now hmm yeah
I wonder if I should get the complete
the total bishop here or just retreat
the knight on c4 is not exactly a bad
piece okay let's just retreat
get be fast before and probably get gets
pace going here before was a really
strange decision and there are a couple
of good moves even light a three is kind
of kind of interesting but okay let's
just push this let's see four D takes
when Bishop see six will be terrible if
it takes on c4 so I can do this first
and consider the details now I guess
Bishop a1
yeah every geek yeah 93 now this was the
original intention and I'm going for it
Bishop c6 Queen d5 this is absolutely
fantastic you see if I can get that in
here c3 are not NS no needs so let's do
this so Queen to d5 Queen g7 King D 7
threatening g8 let's devastation I'm not
I'm not wasting time on this
butchy eight is the threat the cream
cannot leave the G file yeah this is
kind of the only move and now if I go
look here yeah this is probably right
Queen 872 with immediately over okay
so wanna take a look at the analysis of
this game yeah I think it all was
reasonably okay for white until he went
for this before move which was a little
bit mysterious so yeah I mean this is
probably questionable but not not
terrible or anything he's 60 M taking or
97 also was good for sure Psalm 96
Bishop III you can take that b6 move is
actually something that with hindsight I
don't like so much if I take bishop pigs
and probably just a little bit better
here with the two bishops but the thing
is here you know if he goes here now I
don't want to take that's just the worse
version of what the heck could have had
earlier and I probably will keep the
tension and he plays like C 322 white is
fine what is fine I mean the engines has
equal ish yeah I agree I mean this is
probably not that bad
that you should really play 92 now d3
and what's sure about this
mmm-hmm so nothing terrible happen until
this which witches lose is basically
it's a good mysterious to to what what
you miss because I mean I just take
twice and then what yeah this is looking
really really awful is easy easy gamer
you just push the pause idea why this
already completely lost
yeah g8s is deadly to take cm and this
one and look at three actually okay
three I wanted to play look g2 and then
you can see also in this I wanted to
play with mean okay I don't quite know
where there are so many threats in the
game volume this year with Luke g2 so it
would end like this for mate you have I
played them somewhat strange move before
and after that you couldn't save it okay
guys thanks for watching